from Dallas Texas The Flash apparently
official President Kennedy died a
massive Car Bomb exploded outside of a
large Federal Building in downtown
Oklahoma City shattering that Jim just a
few moments ago something believed to be
a plane crashed into the South Tower of
the world of growing concerns about the
deadly Corona virus officially hitting
the
US January 6 was a setup from beginning
to end house Speaker Mike Johnson
recently released 40,000 hours of
January 6 footage Democrats have been
fighting to keep this footage from the
American people because they know if we
see it we know exactly what happened
that day and that totally goes against
their narrative they know we'd see
videos like this of people peacefully
walking through the capital as if
they're on a field trip or this video of
Capitol Police taking the handcuffs off
an individual possibly an FBI agent fist
bumping him and then letting him go but
I know what some people are going to say
what about the violence outside the
capital well let's talk about it for
starters antifa was present at the
capital on January 6th and they're
funded by none other than Public Enemy
Number One George Soros and when you
have Congress asking the director of the
FBI Christopher Ray how many federal
agents were in the crowd or how many
confidential human sources were inside
the capital dressed as Trump supporters
before the doors were open he can't
answer did you have confidential human
sources dressed as Trump supporters
inside the capital on January the 6th
prior to the doors being open again I
had to be very careful no Ray EPS was on
camera inciting an Insurrection I'm
going to put it out there I'm probably
going to go to jail tomorrow we need to
go into the capital into the capital he
actually succeeded and was caught on
camera at the initial breach of the
capital but was only charged with a
misdemeanor meanwhile there are people
who received 20 years in prison who
weren't even at the capital and let's
not forget about the chief of police on
January 6th Steven stun who stated that
the FBI Homeland Security and our
military knew that January 6th was going
to be chaotic we now know that
significant intelligence existed that
individuals had were plotting to storm
the capital building Target lawmakers
And discussing shooting my officers and
yet no Intel agencies or units sounded
the alarm and when all hell broke loose
it took 71 minutes for the National
Guard to be dispatched the New Jersey
State Police showed up before the
National Guard and they're over 4 hours
away they knew January 6 was going to be
insane but they let it happen on purpose
another lie that's been perpetrated by
the left is that multiple officers died
on January 6th that's a lie the only
person that was murdered on January 6th
was Ashley Babbin an unarmed United
States Air Force veteran who was shot in
the neck by Lieutenant Michael bird who
was never charged for the incident and
if you're one of these people walking
around saying that January 6th was worse
than 911 you are an idiot Steve Schmidt
I'm talking to you January 6 was a trap
used to throw in people in prison for
protesting what they thought was a
stolen election and the tapes prove it
thank you guys for watching venting with
Vinnie just an FYI my good friend
Patrick mcdavid's book choose your
enemies wisely comes out December 5th
you can get it on Amazon or you can get
it at Barnes & Noble and if you want to
sign copy of the book head over to
vt.com that being said peace and
love